哈喽同学们大家晚安
来测试一下
现在的声音呢
声音如何
我把麦克风拉过来看看
来了
那我先看一下
前面的一些同学的问题
那
我来调整为
全部的这个聊天系
那我今天的這個TS的單子我有打 我等一下給大家看
我把它繳出來一下 大家應該看得到我了
沒畫面嗎?
真的沒畫面嗎?
等一下等一下
如果没有画面白头发超多
如果看到我的白头发代表解析度是OK的
来那个
我们家有那种白头发的遗传
还好啦至少是白头发不是秃头
我觉得可以接受
我们家有这种白头发的基因
你说太油吗
有可能因为我有抹那个
抹那个发油发辣这样子
就为了直播要抹一下
然后待会洗澡要把它洗掉了
我老婆都说我神经病
晚上这个时间还要再抹发胶
我今天有做TS单
然后我的那个什么express账号
在他前几天的那个当机的那个事件中
我的express账号没得动
所以呢就挂掉了
然后我有跟他申请
他说他今天应该会回复我吧
他有跟我拿资料啊什么的
就看他怎么处理我的express这样
他们最近可能事情很多啊这样子
不过说真的这样子爆掉
你会觉得觉得很不爽你知道吗
身為交易的人就是你的單子本來是賺錢的
結果因為他不能動
然後最後這樣子變賠錢出場等等
你就會覺得很悶你知道嗎就最近的這一天那这是我重新我重新就直接
既然报掉
好我想说好
在他处理的过程中
我昨天开这个新的150K的账号
那我是直接开他那个什么
没有启动费的那个
这样
反正我可以很快的这样子搞定
所以这两天
这个账号是昨天才开始开的
你看一下
昨天才开的账号
昨天
你看交易日只有两天
到目前是这样子
就昨天跟今天
那昨天的交易
就都在图上
我刚好做的都是小纳
这就是昨天我有贴出来给大家看的
我说我去打棒球
打棒球出掉
这里有看到那个-5
打棒球
我要练球
然后把它出掉
然后后来这边我有摸一下
但是都是你看成本价
摸在91
IB出在93,反正就是成本价出掉
玩一下,没有完成功就不玩了
然后后来今天早上在这边
这样子
对啊,所以
这个没有办法
IB的桌面
图表下面的,对我IB还没登入,大家等我一下
等我一下
他登入还要
还要用我的
我的脸
等一下
等我一下
好
这像这样子的登入我觉得好
因为至少他是
是有安全机制的
特斯要创新高
对啊特斯要创新高了
然后我有在底下吃这个
这里
这是我在底下吃的
我现在已经拉到这个地方
然后呢
我最近在这边吃
这是
前面那个是不赔
这个是不赔被打掉
你看
前面在这边
吃在这里
不赔打掉
然后这个吃
吃
然后这里有停损
这个吃
停损
然后我发现
这个是破底番好好吃
结果被这个打不赔打掉
那运气很好
我刚好有看到这里
下来没有等第一个发现还是下不去好好吃吃看各位我有吃很大的部位吗没有啊我才吃四口微型的因为我也还在测试这个市场
尤其是结算前的这种波动
我很很不容易掌握
所以我就降部位
想说好反正四口摸摸看
如果摸赢了
那我慢慢等结算
这个是三月份的仓位
回来再慢慢加
六口八口十口
这样慢慢一路加上去
这样都可以
这是我的部位
特斯拉就抱着
我记得我一直就都跟大家讲说
我就是一直抱着特斯拉
我没有什么想法
这边创新高
小亚当大亚当满足
创新高会这种拉回
这很正常的事情
这样好不好
好来
那我现在要干嘛呢
现在来看一下大家的问题
我们来看一下
最近有一个同学在我的影片底下有留言
他问我有关于9914梅利达
他前一段时间问我说可不可以吃
我跟他说不行
因为他的这个惯性都还没有结束
甚至也没有那种很明确的收
整理收下影线的这种破了又回来
所以我跟他讲说还不行
你看到包含周线
如果你现在要吃这个
这个美丽达的周线
还早嘞
不行
老鱼它不是有下影线吗
有啦
它有下影线
但是它发生的位置不对
如果这个K棒的下影线
没有这么低
它在这里
在这里
刚破
然后下影线在这里
那我会跟你说
这个好多了
但是它太低了
太低了就容易引起连锁效应
这样一路下去
所以这个
真的不行
那我从前面几个看一下
是不是真的很下来要求自己只打高品质的单
才算通过这个成年礼
算是
但是你也不用给自己太大压力
你的成年礼
你应该要想象成是像当兵
海军路战队要出关
以前要爬过天堂路这样
我不是海路的
你看我的身材就不是海路的
你要像那种感觉一样
去承受一些大培的经验爆调的经验今天我要聊的其实是我自己各种爆掉各种大赔的经验其实这些经验造就了现在的我能够
赚得到钱能够
好好的持有这些部位
这样子
好吧 那我手上很多财富
其实也是因为这样子
而赚到的
是因为踩了好多洞
那个是坑 会掉下去
我掉下去过
好以后不要踩
又掉下去一次
哎呀再提醒自己第二次
所以你不要想说
你一定要变得很完美
才要长大
不用
我们每个人
我现在讲的不单纯在交易
我们每个人都是边跌倒
边往前走
你创业也是
工作也是
就是一边跌倒试试看
试错就算了
就学好经验
然后再往前走
跌倒了
爬起來再往前走
再跌倒又爬起來
你就做這件事情
然後一段時間以後
你可能一年後你再回頭過去看
哎呀我這一年走的很坎坷
有沒有路上各種凹凸不平的
但是我走過來了
所以你一年後回頭看
你會發現哇我長長好多
在當下你會沒有感覺這樣好不好
那有同學說不堪回首的鬼打牆
真的有辦法走出來嗎
這個我等一下聊好不好
待會我或許應該有機會聊到這些
我把它截圖提醒我自己
這樣
來看一下股票
這個吧
凱拓
拓凱
不要理我
拓凯
算是Io的吗?可以耶
周线可以哦,日线
日线也有这个样子
这里这里这里
也不错不错
搭配上周线,那我跟你说
像这样子啊
再拉大一点的格局,这个不错
那拉大格局你就知道这个框框附近
这个附近
上上下下都是我们的周线等级的打击区
所以你到日线来讲其实你不用太紧张
这边也可以 这边也可以 这边也可以 反正约略就是这个
区域 158 159 160
约略留在这
这整体而言的这个K棒不错
而且它这根还有力道可以征服的
这几根的这个下跌的这个角度
所以它近期内
它必须要想办法撑在大约这附近
我这样目测约略了158以上
只要可以在这边
那这整个东西就后市就很不错
那如果我是你
我的建议是这样子
是你不要一次百分之百的部位直接吃进去
我的习惯
10% 10% 10%
十分之一十分之一的部位
所以你可以先在这边吃个十分之一十分之二
行情继续震荡
十分之一十分之二再下去
它需要有一个宽度
所以你不需要说觉得说你错过很可惜
它左边的宽度跟右边的宽度
常常会约略的一样
简单的说让它震荡一下
然后你慢慢慢慢的
透过时间这样慢慢过去
你把部位慢慢建起来
不用一次丢
但是整体而言你的选股我觉得很不错
然后同学问说会建议练习到什么阶段
再买考试账号比较适合
我跟你说
在纯练习阶段
因为没有资金压力
你会发现你做得好顺好顺
对不对
模拟单
你做得跟神一样
各种纪律都做得出来
然后各种标准图
你都很舍得勇敢按
对不对
然后等到有金钱压力
有通关压力
有真钱的感觉的时候
挖了对吧
那我想跟你说的是
只要你能够活在市场上
你用模拟单
我先不管赚多少钱
你能够活着一周到两周
你已经可以不要到大赔了
基本上只要不大赔
虽然不见得会赚
但是只要不大赔
你已经可以开始进入这种考试的角度
因为它的成本很低
就会让你有心理上面有金钱的那个刻度感
所以我自己认为对于一个新手来讲这是最低成本你也先不要用增仓去测试自己的新的地方当然它终究跟增仓是不一样
但是它已经开始带有那个感觉
我觉得不需要等到你在模拟交易
把自己磨到100%完美的才要进场
没有这回事
市场上面包含交易也没有100%完美
跟很多人创业一样
他一定是创业计划书
一定要写得超级详细
以后创业的什么东西
都要搞得超级明确
才要走出第一步
不要
想个三成五成
差不多了
走了
对
创业也是这样子
交易也是这样
因为你需要借由这个行进间的事情
来让自己学会东西
这样好不好
合硕4938
合硕
日线可以用边界2来摸吗
不行不行不行
来来来
这是个非常好的案例
一个好的边界是这样子
注意看
边界有整理
然后下来打破的这里
所以按照这支合硕来讲
前一段时间的这个地方
这个
如果你跟我说这个地方要来做边界二
那这个我给过
这个可以
有没有
围棋大概将近一个月的边界
然后你说边界二可以
但是眼前这个
来
应该上去回来了
请问你
这个地方
它是前面是
它是破底的边界吗
我刚刚遮住后面这边的这根
这一根它是破底的
有破底
这里没破底
而且它是不是一个往下的K棒很凶
所以不行不行
忍一下
忍到什么时候
我不知道
目前这样再下去
就算这边出现
除非它出现了一个这样子的K棒
然后这里
这里
下来破边界收回来
这个隔壁你说边界二可以我可以给过
他需要这样子要破好不好
好那把家里所有的技术
从此把交流群
赚钱再自然也不够
我们等一下进入主题之前
我先给大家看一下
我手边的一些
我觉得比较好的交易的书
这些其实很多都是跟心理学有关的
这本跟刚刚同学推荐的那个一样
就是什么赚钱再自然不过
这个也是马克道格拉斯他写的
这本叫做
他书名很长
英文叫Trading in the Zone
这本也不错
但是他的书其实你看完你会发现
其实跟我们一直在讲的东西都差不多
还有呢
这种一流的人如何如何什么
保持巅峰
这种
那其实这些书跟
跟刻意练习
待会我这边旁边也有放
这些书其实他跟我们讲说
很厉害的这些运动员
很专业的钢琴家
他们如何保持在那个程度
像这样子
其实不外乎是什么
是练习
而且里面这些书
他们都会提到一个很好玩的东西
叫做脑袋的运动
脑袋的静心
那也是一种锻炼你脑袋的地方
所以他们很大量在
专注在你的情绪的稳定等等
还有呢
这个亚当理论就不用说了
亚当理论是我们推荐的书里面
很重要的一本书
不过我的交易法不是用他的
他的突破型的这种交易法
不是
我们是拉回买
我是拿他来翻亚当的
好不好
然后
幽灵的礼物
这本
他就像是
就像人家访问一样
你会看到说
里面很多是访谈的感觉
一个记者
然后另外一个是trader
然后在访问的过程中
来来回回
然后告诉你
他在做什么做什么
这本也很不错
这个推荐给大家
然后呢
你看我这边的书都不是那种
都不是那种什么环宇出版社里面
然后厚厚的技术分析
然后什么的都不是这些反而都是偏心态偏偏大腦然後像這個 少但是更好這種我也很喜歡
我相信這些書大家很多人都有
然後這一本練習的心境
這本也是好書一本
所以我這邊蠻多跟練習有關
你看還有光練習就還有另外兩本
一本是刻意練習
一本是完美練習
其實你看完以後發現他們大部分都是在做類似的事情
就是不要怕然後就走出去慢慢來
其實到後來我發現交易基本上是同一件事
好來
所以有人說其實你們看我的東西
幾乎都已經涵蓋了這些書的內容
当然不可能是全部 这些都是好书
但是你会发现
就是你钻研到后面
厉害的这些人 他们在做的事情
万变不离其中
都是大道自检的这种类似的事情
而且也都很大量的强调心理的重要
好 书讲完了
那我们来聊今天的这个主题
然后慢慢的聊到
聊到我这些跌倒的过程
希望给大家一些经验
我叠过的这些东西都很痛
那我希望不要再复制在各位身上
有机会在耶诞节时送老鱼的书给喜欢的女生吗
你送我的书给人家
你是准备分手吧
不要啦
在圣诞节送一本跟交易有关的书
你早死了
對不對 來
然後我現在手上有看到旁邊同學說
那些有關於記住分析的書
對我那些書基本上已經全丟了
我以前手上有一大堆
《環宇出版社》其實它有出好多各種記住分析
然後有的是一本就是一種記住分析
有的是綜合的這種
哇我全部都看過
然後死的很慘
OK
我的書還沒啦
我很在努力 我真的很努力的在写
来 从最早期的我开始聊
我在韭菜阶段我是不小心
赚到钱
那段时间的股市跟
前一段时间无条件
大概就是从4月到10月
的股市你眼睛闭着按下去做多就会赚钱的这种感觉
一样
那我
刚好是在后半段
这段狂涨的时候
进来当韭菜
我赚到钱
把十几万变成快要200万
哇好强好厉害
那结果
很快速的
在大概一个月内
不只把这个钱赔掉
我还倒赔
那我当时怎么做
我当时就是一路赚钱
我记得我赔钱的第一天
是赔30万
我这辈子第一次在
我讲过这故事
第一次在股市里赔到这种
30万台币的这种金额
然后那时候的我才是一个
刚20出头税
刚毕业的刚当完兵的那种感觉没多久这样
然后所以就觉得自己好像很恐怖一样
30万耶
但是当时户头还有一百多
隔天就再赔一个30
所以两天60就不见了
我还记得我说过隔天一大早
我的我一大早9点半以前
我的30万第二个30万就赔掉了
然后我就从大概九点半
我就这样呆呆的
就这样坐在荧幕前面
然后也不讲话
然后我老婆在旁边
她就睡她的
然后我那时候就在房间里
弄一台电脑就这样子做
然后呢
太多不敢吵我
我就这样子呆呆的坐着
一路坐
坐到什么时候
坐到中午
都不用上厕所
不用吃早餐
不用喝水
我就这样一路坐着
然後看著行情在跳動
好恐怖的世界
那反正
那段時間我做的事情很笨
我跑去買了選擇權
我是到很後期才知道選擇權的買方
對他賺的時候很快沒錯
但是一旦方向不對的時候
他賠的速度更快更快
快到很誇張
然後
我當時第一天賠完的時候
我心里面抱着的想法是我隔天要把它赚回来所以我当天手上剩下的100多万我直接买call我买的是买价平跟价外
三四档就是比较便宜的那种
因为那个一旦翻起来就翻很多
反正我就买买买买买
按按按五口五口五口五口的买
跌下来买 跌下来买买买
买到系统跳出那个保证金不足
不够五口
你知道我做什么事吗
拆三口可以 两口可以 一口可以
我把我的保证金按满 满到
连50块都用进去的 这种满这样
就是全部都用进去
然后这样子的流仓
我现在回头过来看
如果是现在的我回到十几年前
回到2007年的我
我会一头敲下去 干你在干嘛
你知道这样子换算下来
真正的部位
真正等值的股票的部位有多大吗
一头敲下去
你这个年轻人你承受得起吗
反正隔天就再赔30
我那些钱很快的在一个月内赔掉
各种凹单乱做都在那个时候
然后后来我还跟我妈借钱
然后整个借完钱回来
還是很快賠掉
因為我根本不知道我自己在幹嘛
然後我就跑去到處學
學書上的啦
書上說不靈通道這樣做啦
說那個葛蘭畢八大法則啦
說KD指標啦
RSI黃金交叉啦
反正書上寫的我基本上我都有做過
然後做的時候越做越亂
所以錢就很自然的繼續賠掉
一直到呢
我因缘忌讳之下认识了一个阿伯
总之那个阿伯在中部的券商里面很有名
然后我有机会去他家跟着他看盘
他还蛮阿沙里的就直接让我去
我其实很感谢他
因为我最经典的那两句话是他跟我讲的
就是我跟他在
我还没去他家以前我们出来吃饭
然后我就问他说
那个什么阿伯啊
你做交易有没有什么美感他就跟我讲说你就买在跌不下去的地方卖在涨不下去的地方然后就继续吃披萨当时我的心里面
我心里面在骂
我就笑笑的跟他讲
这样子
不知道大家听不听得懂
我刚骂什么东西
我想的是
买在跌不下去的地方
卖在涨不下去的地方
我也会
如果我会我就不用来找你
这句话我也会讲
然后我就迟一迟就继续问他
他说你看久了就会
什么看久了就会
我可不可以去你家跟你看
去
结果我去他家
对他只给我心法
我回家自己乱练会练篇
我去他家看
我想说我就跟在他旁边看
我一定可以看出一些端倪来
结果我去到他家完蛋了
他在客廳看吧
那三个大电视
因为他有年纪了
当时他应该已经有60岁多了吧
我不知道持继几岁
总之三个大电视
然后其中一个
其中一个是接无声的非凡新闻
就是那个跑股票跑马灯的那个台
无声他就是看那个数字在跳这样
然后另外两个是接电脑
然后他电脑里面没有各种图表
没有像这种没有没有图
没有这个他的萤幕上面只有这个来
他的萤幕上只有只有这种东西
然后跟跟那个报价
我例如说例如说例如说
我把他的萤幕上只有这个
只有我用给大家看他的萤幕
只有一个这个对就这样就这种东西
然后就在那里跳来跳去
然后说他的萤幕开的是开日元
期货跟日金指数的期货
讲日元跟日金
他的日金指数
他就是还有做新加坡的日金
跟美国那边的日金
就是他有在两个地方上架
他就这样看
然后眼睛盯着数字盯着盯着
然后就电话拿起来
就打给营业员
我说这边帮我挂
50口70口的多单
买日币在什么什么价格
这样
然后过一段时间
荧幕上这个地方就出现他的挂单
就这样子
然后就看到挂单在那边
然后被吃掉吃掉吃掉
成交了
然后就看到浮动盈亏在那里跑来跑去跑来跑去同一时间我的电脑我带着笔电过去我在旁边笔电上面各种切线
各种指标
我只差没有多带一个萤幕来接出去而已
我的萤幕乱七八糟
然后旁边这个老大
大行不过
然后就躺在他的双人床
他放在客厅就直接这样躺着
就这样看
然后也没在干嘛
就在一边跟我聊天
一边这样看
就看著這個數字
我說大哥你在看什麼
就這裡啊
剛剛這個25097這邊就下不去啊
現在到103嘛
我剛剛切過來的時候
我的眼睛看到是097下不去啊
他就這樣啊
然後就就做做做做
那個時候他在元大起貨做交易
所以如果沒有認識元大起貨的營業員
你们可以跟他探听看看这个人
他现在不自在那边
他现在已经退休了
年纪很大了
人家要退休好好的过生活了
那当时是在远大
总之
你看像现在到105
来来来
要上去要上去怎么样
就一边聊天
对
然后呢
在这个过程中
我在他家那边待了
大概两周
我不确定精确时间
反正就是我也没有每天去
大概隔天隔天隔天
所以一个礼拜去个两天到三天
大概是这样子
然后去到两周多
他就让我去
他还把他家楼下那个一楼大门的BB的感应扣给我
我这么相信我这样子
会不会赚是知识的东西
好讲到跟单
我跟了
结果呢好时不时我就跟着日币的单子
那时候是安倍晋三正要宣布日元的一个
什么三支箭的那个什么政策
他们针对日币的汇率
然后做出一些政策这样子
安倍晋三那个年代
然后在宣布前他就觉得他有一些自己的判断
像我刚刚这边我刚刚说97下不去
你看现在就往上来有没有
然後呢
那時候的我
來
他下了日幣
50口70口坦白講
我真的忘记到底多少
反正就是这种部位
然后日币的保证金
日元期货的保证金
当时一口大概折合台币8万多块钱
我就拿了一个10万当保证金
所以我按下去的瞬间我就满仓了对吧
我说他买这个价格
我也就在旁边拿电脑我就跟着买
跟大户的单我总不会错的吧
结果没有
为什么
因为他凹单了
大哥你没有走
我觉得我想要赌他
就是几天后
当时好像两三天后
公布这个三支箭的政策
我要赌赌看
然后结果到最后一天的时候
他跟我说
中正我觉得这次
可能连我都会亏
我可能看错了
当时的浮动亏损
是付大概500多万
那个时候
我身为一个小咖
我刷到要死
因为我的部位已经赔了七八万
所以我当天
刚好也是保证金余额不足的那个时候
然后就只好被迫的砍仓
砍在一个很奇怪的阿呆鼓
但是我没有钱
然后他跟我说他可能也会赔
但是他没有出场
他说我决定跟他好好看
这样
结果呢
他就熬过去了
熬过去那个月赚了一千多万
就在我面前
他熬过去
我呢
我的钱不够
我躺在地上死掉了
为什么我明明跟他的单
因为我后来才发现
对底下这句话
感觉他是不是本多宗圣
也算
但是这就很神奇的是
他并不是把两亿的资金
他没有下满到两亿
的保证金全部拿下去下单
你懂我意思吗
他的浮动亏损500万的这一块
对他的总部位来说
他根本
他可以继续去睡觉
他都没有关系的感觉
但我不行啊
我只有10万
然后直接拿里面的8万去做期货
期货又是有带着20倍左右的杠杆
所以简单的说
我开了超大的杠杆
对所以他教我的没有错他教我的没有错他也凹单了但是我死很惨
他没有
我后来慢慢去理解他的交易
原来他的科度是大科度
我跟人家在那边用个什么五分K几分K的
没有
他是用周线的那种等级的大科度在看盘
所以他的资金
他的刻度本来就会变大
但是我到很后期
我才想通这件事
我没有那个卡撑
就硬要去跟人家做大刻度的事情
那当然都是死得很惨
对吧
阿贝有没有算看错
我是不觉得
因为我如果从
我把他的刻度拉到
大的周线月线来看
他的确吃在相对的
低点或高点的边界上
他的确是吃在这里
只是短线态啊
他也没有办法控制
这样
对就这样子了
好不好
那
他的这个钱
的这个刻度
我
我望尘莫及
但是那次给我的一个很深刻的体验就是
人家的荧幕上面只有
来
他的荧幕只有这个
现在回到104了
刚刚下不去是97
我现在看到104
对吧
那他萤幕上只有这个
人家就可以赚钱
他还同时间看日经指数
看那个日元期货的报价这样
然后就可以做交易
我的萤幕乱七八糟
我在乱什么的啦
他什么都没有看耶
他赚钱耶
然后最近台积电到1500 1400
各位有没有遇到身边有一些人
他的台积电买在多少
200多300多甚至60块的
可能是菜市场卖菜的阿嬷
台积电买在60块
他什么都不会看
也不知道自己有台积电的股票
10年后打开来看
哎呦 到底探急呢
有没有
所以各位
我们做的要死要活的干嘛
对不对
把刻度放大一点
好吗
来
那
后来我仍然很穷很苦
我说过我把钱赔掉
我又带着两个小孩
那段时间
有一段时间我是全职交易
我跟我老婆说
老婆我不去找工作了我就靠交易我可以的你看我曾经一个月赚这么多钱一天是两万三万台币在赚的
一天
我靠这个就可以
所以我就跑去借钱借信贷
我信贷的利息很高
借来干嘛
你知道我借信贷来的想法很简单
我想要再复制一次
复制什么
复制我把10万变成200万
我可以把10万变200
那我有100万
你觉得我脑袋在想什么
我脑袋想的就是随便翻都把几千
哇
古神
我就是要从这边开始
我差一点去学后空翻了
结果你看底下的
不到一个月就亏完了
对
因为我对我自己的那个期待
那个压力大到不行
我希望我用我的全职交易的
的那个钱来养家活口
养两个小孩
缴他们的幼稚园学费
然后生活费
还可以带老婆出去玩
然后看可不可以
赚到房子的头期款
对
我跑去信贷
因为我当时很穷
谁要借我
所以就是利率很贵的信贷
才会借我
这样
所以就跟
当时就跟银行借的信贷
我问你
我一个月赔掉以后
银行会跟我说
说什么
余先生
我看你很辛苦
不然这样子
你这些钱不用还了
银行会这样子
不会吧
银行是什么
我管你怎么赔的
那是你家的事
你跟我借的钱加上利息
对
你就是要还
所以我等于是借来的钱
瞬间不见了以外
我还要再还我借来的这100万
我后来才知道
这个很恐怖很恐怖的世界
好吗
所以
而且你想不到一个月就亏了
我说当时指数不是两万多点
是七千点九千点
就长期都还在万点以下的那个时候
那你想那个时候跳动也还好
我居然也可以
不到一个月就把这个钱赔掉
就代表我一定是凹单
或是大单加凹单
那就一定是死得很快啊各种选择权也做各种期货也做大台也做那100万进来一下子一开始一定是大台加选择权后来钱赔掉了
大台不够做
就是小台加选择权
到后来
到后来就是
就是只剩选择权
然后把它按按按
这个100万要按到剩零头
你知道吗
就是不足50块
连一口都买不起的那种
好不好
然后你才甘愿这样子
所以那些我觉得我应该手上要刺一下那个
刺个半甲
然后理个阿字头去跟去证券公司前面跟他呛一下
对不对
你怎么没有模拟单给我
是这样吗
钱没有不见
只是跑到对方身上
我跟大家讲
然后人家说什么我顶着这么大压力还能变一代宗师来
我不是一代宗师拜托比我厉害的人
比比皆是
好不好
1000个10000个到处都是
我只是踩过的地雷比较多的人
这样
好吧
那这个待会我就到最后面再来聊好不好
这一段因为跟你刚刚说这个翻身的这个过程
来
然后还有我后来进了券商
你知道在券商里面
你自然而然会看到一些怪物对吧
然后我有一个同事
他的职称是营业员
但是他不接外面的单
他当营业员的目的就是接自己的单
因为他单量够大
所以券商愿意让他
就不需要去做外面的生意了
他就当他自己的营业员
就这样就好了
然后结果那位同事他很会赚
但是他的交易法跟我的完全不同
他是那种例如说他那次
川普刚当选的那次
那时候的小道琼在17000的时候
这样
然后他是
行情在这边他是往底下挂
买买买买买买 往下挂
然后当天晚上我还记得他传讯息给我说
老鱼怎么办
他往下挂穿架
整个川他当时做的那个是小纳
他还有做德子
德国指数是大德子
德子的那个合约规格超大的
然后总之就是往下穿下来
然后他就成交成交成交全部凹单
他当时账上是负800万台币
那他当时整个户头里他还有截图给我看
很可惜没有留下来
那个截图是他账上当时户头里有2000多万
然后那个未平仓损利是负800万
就这个部位这样子
然后他说怎么办
我就问他说你要怎么办
他说我就凹了凹到明天看看
结果选川普当总统那天
大家不知道记不记得
我们台湾时间的下午狂杀
晚上狂杀
结果半夜直接
瞬间一根大V转整个喷回去
所以他隔天早上一翻上来
赚一千万多
一千多少万我不知道
那他的事情
总之他是这种
下来吃凹
然后弹回去大赚
他是这种
那他后来有没有报
坦白讲我不知道
他也是有他的交易的能力在
他的交易能力是真的还不错
只是我们两个的做法是截然不同
那你说我会不会去跟他比较
有一次过年思维
那一年那个月我刚好在做
做那个A50
就是中国A50期货
我当时在做那个
然后我做的是在
当时是在新加坡交易所上架的
那个A50期货
然后那一年思维
那时候我们两个就刚好坐旁边
那时候我已经在群艺了
然后他就说你这个月赚多少
自然会问吧
我那个月赚大概50多吧
然后我就问说你呢
我这个月现在这样100多吧
150上下
我就哇好强哦
然后他就说你这个月
最多的浮动亏损到哪里
我说浮动亏损
大概5万块吧
就是我只有最一开始建仓的时候
有那个一开始建仓的成本
可能的亏损
后来已经进入了不赔的状态
我就只是抱着跟家部位这两件事情而已
一路这样做起来
我记得那时候是赚18000美金
还19000美金
就是那个月
他就说我好佩服你
我说为什么你赚比我多
他说没有啊
我是从负两三百万拗回来变正150
他说他比较佩服我
可以用这么低的风险可以拗回去这样子
以结果论他赚的比我多
你知道那天回来我脑袋里会有一个隐隐约约的想法就是人家这样子可以赚那么多不如我也来试试看
对
所以我会想要比较
就是人家赚这样子
我赚的不够多
一比较就挂了
所以下一个月我都不敢跟他见面
遇到他就赶快躲
为什么
为什么赶快躲
因为下一个月我猜他是赚钱的
但是我赔的稀里花
因为我用了一个根本不属于我的交易法
我想学它
人家是凹单的
我又没有放很多钱去跟他凹
而且我的心
你知道我的本质上凹不下去
然后所以我的下个月就亏钱
他这样走钢索
晚上会不会睡不着觉
他就真的我们讲心脏很大科的这种
但是事实上我认为
在期货的市场上面
心脏很大科不见得是好事
心脏大科代表你愿意压大
压大你赚钱的时候自然会赚得多
但是各位会有赔钱的时候
你压大赔钱的时候赔钱怎么办
赚钱的速度快赔钱也一样快
两边是一模一样的速度
那怎么办
但是我们人都只会想到赚钱的时候
所以我那个潜意识的比较心态
就算我跟我老婆说
没有啦我不在乎她的单
但是一旦坐到电脑前面来
我就是会不知不觉的
想到啊
人家这个交易法我停损
我在停损的时候
人家在凹单
他凹上去赚钱
不然我也试试看好了
然后就没有然后了
好不好
再来
然后前一段时间去年还前年吧
我忘记了应该是去年
就是开始兴盛这种暴障流
这样应该已经两三年了
所谓暴障流的意思就是
它不是用我们正规的这种风险控制
然后部位控制的这种交易法
它去考那种外面各种考试的这种机构
考过了它就给你钱
然后让你出金等等
然后他就是花信用卡的刷卡费
然后一次买10个20个多少个账号一次买一大堆然后这个大单没过爆掉没关系下一个
反正就是大单靠一波
然后就抓那个靠一波过的这种
所以他只要他的基数够
例如说一开始像金字塔一样
他只要底下的账号筛选用的账号够
这样
然后到这边
到这边
他到最后面一路塞上来
总是会有不小心给你骰子
有没有
或是直铜板
不小心连续直到两次三次
四次都是正面的铜板
总是会出现
对吧
所以最上面就会有某几个账号
是可以出金
这种他们就是一样大单的打
假设有两个好了
一个大单打多单
一个大单打空单
待会其中一个一定会赚钱
所以就把这个的初金拿出来用
这样是稳赚对不对
但是他们是在洗那个制度
这不是我们正规教育法的模式
然后你说我看到人家这样子初金几万几万
你说我的心不会觉得很
就不爽你知道吗
就是我乖乖的遵守纪律
乖乖的用微型的
然后先小部位的再打
因为我把它当成是我的真仓
一样在做
然后结果人家是
叭叭叭叭叭叭
他们在玩制度
我也没有说人家是对是错
但是你知道看了就会觉得
那一股气就会在这边
然后特别有些时候是
有些网友会回来呛我
老鱼你才赚三千美金
那个谁谁谁
随便都把赚三万美金
哇
然后我就一整个
一整个狙起来你知道吗
就是妈的我在这边
你懂这种感觉
但是我们的做法是正规的
是我把这个账号
当成是自己的真钱账号来做
这是对的事情
但是却被这个给洗走了
我的心也跟着跑掉
所以我当时有live账号
后来就因为这样子
我把我的live账号给打掉
为什么
就是超不爽
拎杯做给你看
但是我又瞬间膨胀了
我又做了一个不属于我原来在做的事情
就是这样子但是网路上很多人到现在还是这样他们一个月的刷卡金额一万美金两万美金的在刷
一个月
我要你真的去赔
你还不见得会赔到一万美金
对吧
但是他光刷卡就刷掉一万美金
能不能出金
不知道碰运气
有时候可以
说不定有些时候还不行
说不定一百个人里面
可能有前面那两个三个五个
能够借由这种方式出金
但是一百个人里面有绝大多数的
都是每个月狂刷卡双刷卡
一直reset一直reset
其实人家那些券商
那些平台商
他就是在赌这件事情
他就是在赌你赚不起来
他在赚这种钱
这就不是我最一开始
想要推荐大家用这种做法的初衷
不是
这样
我那个live账号
护城河两万七千多
照样瞬间被我打爆
两万七千多在帐上
一天
对
好 然后再来
这个是我跟我老婆
这个经典案例我在书中有
这样子
然后跟老婆吵架
反正就在客厅什么原因不知道
这个是在很早期的事情
那时候我的全部的家产还有负债
全部的家产加一加
就是全部的钱
就是大概台币150万以下
然后
对啊 所以就是很不爽
我那天就是整个很不爽
然后呢
我说后来
我说这次跟老婆吵架这次
反正进房间
就是这样喔
我的电脑是常态性开着
开着看盘画面
连那个下单夹就是这个
就是这个
连这个
这个都开着
就是这样常态性的这样开着
所以那时候我一坐下来的第一秒钟
我就直接在这边
我就看着图
就开始按
坐下来的第一秒
我都不用看图
都不用干嘛
那我当天开的是1分K
然后
然后刚好是美股的交易时间
所以行情的波动就像现在这样子
...这样上下上下
有色停損
一下子就被停損掉
可惡不爽
再来不爽再来
刚刚两口被打掉不爽
四口
或是不管了
多多多多多多
五口六口七口八口九口九口九口
一直按一直按
突然间部位变很大
赚钱了出一些出一些
赔钱了再加加加
结果居然赔很多
怎么办怎么办
停損停損快拿掉
我现在讲的是即时动态
我不知道大家知不知道那种感觉
坐下五分钟我的下单的那个交易记录
有没有
才五分钟而已
我的交易记录已经是
一大堆
然后当天的我
那个整个怒气
就是跟老婆吵架的那个怒气
各位男生你一定知道
你的男子气概
如果在家里没有得到那种发泄满足
然后尤其是跟老婆吵架
你就吵输了
然后你那个闷在这边很不爽
你一定会想要找一个东西
然后发泄你的男子气概
最直接的就是
就是掌控你手上的金钱
对吧
我一按就是100万
怎么样
100万
十口十口怎么样
爽
多巴胺刺激
一个半小时不到
我只记得
很快的赔掉
那里面
33000里面我早记的没错
大概有3000多美金是手续费
对哦
扣掉那个我还是赔2万多
厉害
这些不是什么模拟单
那个年代没有什么考试账号模拟单
没有这些都是真钱
而且是建立在我们还没有什么钱的时候的真钱
好恐怖
然后我当天走出书房
去到客厅
还是冷战啊
我也不敢跟老婆说什么
这件事情是一直到很后期的
我老婆才从我的直播中
我在讲的时候
她才知道这件事
知道我那一天跟她吵完架进房间
她以为我就只是进房间
可能在打电动吧
结果没有想到是这样子
就恐怖
所以各位
如果你真的有遇到这样子
拜托不要打开下单软体
好吗
就是
打电动都比乱下谈好真的好不好如果你没有老婆的就是你还没有女朋友的你可以去找优雅那个也比下单好
好不好
讲到这个找优雅
其实是真的有效
好不好
对有情绪不下单
心态炸裂都是
是20口20口案对啊对吧
大家都干过这种傻事啊对不对
然后我也还有曾经是另外一天
我忘记什么时候
但是我曾经一个晚上小那哦
就做200多口增仓
那个时候也没有什么模拟单
这些都是增仓
还不包含我的亏损
你知道200多口那个交易记录
你知道券商的那个交易记录
它的字是很细很细很小
如果以我们平常做word来讲
那个大概才十一
十跟十一的那种细的字
然后两百多口已经是可以
一页两页这样
对
所以都不含亏损了
光所需费就这样子
就一个晚上
我是有多有钱可以这样子乱洗
对吧
所以都不对
旁边同学说情绪不好
每次都大赔对吧
然后以前我们还会去玩那个数据公布
在外汇保证金还很深
兴盛的这个时期
那时候还没有虚拟货币的时期
然后外汇保证金他们很喜欢玩什么
非农之夜
在券商端也开始在玩这件事情
然后外汇保证金他们喜欢在非农之夜干嘛
就是这样子
一样行情在这边
非农公布的瞬间会棒棒
行情是这样子跳的
他们就是喜欢在底下挂多单
上面挂空单
这样子
多单吃到弹回来赚钱
空单吃到下来赚钱
反正就是这样
这对他们来说就是马丁格尔的做法
这样
那我先讲到这不要做
不要做
我现在都不要去赌
数据公布的这种瞬间
像刚刚CPI公布
我不需要去赌这个
我的刻度放大了
我不用跟你小臂自销眼镜去赌那个1分K
然後幾秒鐘啪啪啪啪啪啪啪這樣子
不需要
各位有沒有那種經驗
處具公佈看到看到K棒瞬間瞬間從零然後蹲個1秒鐘然後下一秒鐘到天上去然後本來是蹦到天上去
結果在下一秒鐘2秒鐘後
咻的下來變一個長長的長上影線
然後就一路往下跌
我曾經這樣子
我曾經買在這種地方的多單
當時我們那時候做券商在做突破
买在这种地方卖在这里瞬间邦邦
零点几秒我就出场了
赔多少那时候一口单赔200多300多
但华价跟鬼一样
好吗不要好不好
CPI赌输了
你是空单吗
喂等一下如果你是在刚刚这边做空单的人
你真的会见皱哦
我的小娜
这四口赚钱了
看来可以丢着了
如果载我回来
我可以开始慢慢再加部位
赌那种
不是天堂就是地狱
很恐怖
但是我跟你说
地狱的几率高非常的多
天堂几乎没有
偶尔会让你中一次天堂
但是你可能会
十次里面有九次都是地狱
所以你一次天堂赚的钱来不及
不够补
地狱的钱太恐怖了
来 再来
所以收敛一下
很常见的亏损的情形
我相信我踩过这些地雷
我相信大家也都干过这种傻事
刚刚旁边有同学说
除了借钱以外
其他都做了
所以为什么我一直跟大家说
不要借钱去做投资
你知道我眼前的部位
我眼前的美股
我们凹单有啊
但是我就算这个凹单
他亏损的钱
连我的十分之一的总金额都不到吗
对
所以等于说我连十%的亏损都不到
总资金的亏损
所以你觉得我会痛吗
不会痛啊
就跟那个阿伯一样
两亿扣掉500万
他还是两亿啊
我没有两亿
我只是说我没有那么有钱
我还在累积当中这样好不好来所以如果你过去是这样子稳定个一周我要乖乖的打单
我要控制我的情绪
通常会一天爆掉的时候都是这样
例如说你的部位是这样
稳定稳定
你这假设稳定的五天
你通常就会觉得自己
哎呦
蛮厉害的
老婆
我这五天每天都赚钱
我昨天赚500今天赚1000
后天赚2000
我这一周赚不少
你注意看一下这一瞬间
你的眼睛你的脑袋焦点跑到什么东西上去
我当时不是说我全职交易的时候赔了稀里花啦吗
为什么
因为我的脑袋锁定的东西是money
就是只有钱
那我一旦锁定钱里面
我整个人就是吸走了
我刚刚前面讲的那种乱七八糟的凹单
跟过度交易的这种
不外乎就是整个脑袋都在钱上面
对啊
然后你就觉得自己很厉害
台语讲个微醉的狡猾
屁股就翘彩就自己很强
通常这个时候老天爷
他就会直接的当下
就给你一个很大的打击
然后通常这个爆调的前一天
你已经开始有一些迹象
就是浮起来的迹象了
麻吉大哥没有意义啦
麻吉大哥他怎么补他都是很有钱的
人家是几千万美金在玩的
他赔个几百万美金然后什么感觉
那个不一样人家甚至还有开平台
还有我们一般人你直接把他拿来当
当故事来听听就好了
那个跟一般人的交易完全不一样
好不好
来
然后再来
昨天大赚
今天大赚
我以前很常干这种事情
为什么我大赚的时候
隔天会大赚
又是同一件事情
我大赚以后
我的心
又觉得自己很厉害
而且突然间
假设你有50万
突然间多50万
变到100万
你的心里面会怎么样
哦我好厉害哦
这时候你会仍然只下50万的单子吗
不会
你会把剩下的50万也全按下去
因为你想的是要变成200万变成300变成500
反正就是部位有多少就是按单
多少就对了
结果呢
通常的这一天就是在大赔下去
会把你前面赚的钱还赔掉
还加码去借来的钱也赔掉
爸爸妈妈给你的钱也赔掉
老婆给你的钱也赔掉
就是这样子
对吧
然后呢
看到钱
稳定的时候你也看到钱
大赚也看到钱
你就觉得自己好厉害
甚至有些人会故意想要跟人家比较
甚至是去参加国中同学的同学会
上次参加同学会
他们就笑我在做交易
没有赚到钱
下个礼拜要参加同学会
你卖赚给他看
我就不信
我就赚钱去买个包包
赚钱买一只劳力士
带给他看
很多人是这样
有些人他可能是做给爸爸妈妈看
例如说你在做交易
爸爸妈妈不同意
甚至看随你
我是刚出社会的年轻人
我要证明给人家看
看我不是扶不起的阿斗
对
然后就扶不起
每个都叫阿斗
我目前还没有看过那种
那种刚毕业的年轻人
然后拼了老命做交易成功的
没有
我看十几年了
他可能可以短期在这个月很厉害
可以
他可能就刚好逮到一两波
哇好强
但是长期活下来的对不起没有
他可能三个月很厉害就说我要辞职了
然后就全职交易
然后在半年后钱赔光了
就乖乖的回去找工作了
有没有你身边有没有认识这种人
是吧
所以拜托
如果你是年轻人
我刚刚的故事给你当借鉴
请你先干嘛
先好好工作
用你的本业先乖乖存钱
你有存钱了
你有那个底气了
你才有资格跟人家玩
例如说
老于你的SMC还赔一万五
Oracle赔一万八
你怎么搞错啊
然后Google赔一万
你知道吗
这些全部加起来
连我总资金的10%都不到就是这些亏损加起来这样对啊你要怎么说更不用讲我这种资金里面我还有很多钱是早就是从市场上收刮过来的钱
所以某个程度来说
我早就已经是无本交易了
因为这些钱都是别人的子弹
在我的帐上
别人的子弹
然后在我的帐上
过一段时间找底下的股票乱丢
所以我现在就是用别人的子弹
来乱丢的概念
你知道吗
我丢输了没差啊
反正这些子弹从头到尾都不在我口袋里
都是别人的子弹
感觉很好对不对
但是在以前还没有钱的时候的我
我不能做这种事情
因为我就没那些卡车啊
我就没有那样子的资本做这种事情啊
各位可以懂这种意思吗
好不好
通常几岁会开始稳定
我个人觉得需要经过一些社会的历练
这个聊一下是
有一些经验是我在教同学
因为我们教了好多年
可能加上在群艺时期
加一加十年有了
在教同学
那我们会看到很多
还没出过社会的同学
我不是说你的错
因为你没出过社会是正常的事情
但是因为还没有出过社会
所以会觉得会对自己太有自信
简单的说还没有被磨过
被这个社会被这个市场给磨过
会对自己觉得我是神
因为他下的单子会觉得很恐怖
就是大起大落大起大落的这种单子
然后所以他的个性通常会比较不稳定一点
所以经过一段时间的社会历练
我们自己在教
反而比较稳定的族群是谁
是有家庭
然后小孩子稍微
大的大概已经到高中以后的女生
注意
女生
我们教过这么多学员里面
大概年纪在40岁
50岁
这个年纪的女生
她经历一点社会历练
可能股市赔的钱也赔过了
对吧
小孩子也可能已经高中了
这样
然后这个时候的他我们跟他讲什么东西
因为他赔过
所以他会乖乖的遵守纪律干嘛干嘛的
反而这样子的同学通关的出经的默默的这种好多然后他们交出来的作业都很标准很漂亮他就乖乖的等他也不会过度交易也不会干嘛这样
然后反而是男生
男生脑袋里想的东西就很多你知道吗
男生就很想要
就是那个想要证明想要跟人家比大小
对吧
男生就是有那种气在那边
那个男子气概
所以甚至有些时候男生
我们在调整他的交易法的时候
他还会反驳回来说
不就这样子吗
不就那样子吗
那个针锋相对的感觉很重
反而这种
我们很努力要调他
还不见得能够调
这个很难调
这样
好不好
被说中了
跟同学说你要早点退休
不要啦
不要早点退休了
你现在才几岁
我假如记得没错
你应该很年轻才对
我跟你说退休这件事情是
如果你都能够赚到退休
它是会自然而然发生
你会赚到某个程度
你自然而然会觉得工作好像没有什么必要
赚到某个程度你会觉得
我好像可以了
你会默默的做到这件事
你不会直接在现在就许愿说
我要退休我要全职交易
好不好
不要哦
那个是会自然发生的
好吗
男子气贷跟吃素有关吗
没有
我吃素十几年了
我亏钱的时候
我在固执的时候还是很固执
还是一样
同学在看股票
对不对
我们看一下
不然都这样聊这些
AMD
AMD的小时K
不错耶
日线
不错啊
周线
周线也不错
所以日线的
日线比较麻烦
因为它现在这个位置
现在价格在203
这个位置你怎么吃
基本上你的防守都还是在最下面
所以可能要拉到195这里
这样啊
对啊
如果可以的话
在小10k 它正在噴嘛
打擊區域就是這一塊啊如果回來200這邊很好啊因為如果回來這里震荡你是不是就可以找得出一个这种规律来AMD不错啊
CRWV 这是什么啊
这是什么
因为这个也不错的样子看一下周线
周线也不错
日线
来还需要再多等一下下
不用太急好不好
他刚破然后刚起来不用太急
所以在小时可以刚这样子
你其实等两个东西
他如果跌下来他不能再跌破这边
他可以回来这里鬼混可以
不能再破了
这样好不好
来聊一下
模拟单练习里面
看一下哦
如果你的情绪跟做真相很接近
是不是很难练是坏事
太多人模拟单都是五感做
所以你需要做两件事
你需要先在模拟单里面五感做
你要练到模拟单里面五感做得很棒
然后下一步
如果你都会讲模拟单
代表你有在考试账号里面
你花钱花个50美金100美金
去弄一个账号来参加他们的这个考核
你会开始有争钱感
你需要跟这个有争钱压力的感觉共存
要习惯这个共存
因为从假钱到争钱的这个过渡时期
很多人跨不过来
因为它是
它永远都是在分这个分界
你知道吗
所以最好的其实反而是什么
是你一边练
一边让你的心态去习惯
好我把它当争钱来做
慢慢的做慢慢的做这样
你必须要做到这件事情
這樣好不好
很久沒來了
Hello Hello
1414日線今天進場
是嗎1414
我們看一下1414
今天進場16.9
這樣給過嗎
周線不錯
日線16.9
在這裡
可以啊
我覺得很不錯啊
可以可以
在这边嘛
哦
很好很好
还有什么
哎
还有什么1618
还有上面问建长的1618
等一下
来来来问1618的周线算破里翻的好位置吗
不行
位置对了
但是惯性不对
还不行
而且你眼前看到
斜斜的平平的
包含日线
不要乱吃
我目前看到的力量
像是各种上影线各种本来的支撑变压力
如果他有出现这种明确的破底
又拉回来会有某一天假设有某一天
哇好夸张的急杀
你就在旁边看戏
你就旁边看戏就这样看戏
看戏
你要学那个那个阿伯
这样子看也可以
反正
如果出现这个又瞬间被当天的尾盘
还是中间被哇整个买回来
水
这个的隔壁一天才是我们醒过来的时候
眼前这个还没哦
各位忍一下忍一下哦
好不好
看影片三年最近才开悟
不错啊
这样子比念大学还快啊
大学要四年啊
对吧
事实上
包含我刚刚最一开始推荐的这些书
这些东西
它里面讲到的都不是在
啊
书掉了
等一下 书哲到了
好
他里面讲到的都不是在一两天就能够搞定的事情
就是他们要能够练到某个程度的这个稳定度也好
或是某个程度的优秀也好
他都需要用年的角度来算的
一个好的钢琴家 好的小提琴手
是不是都需要好几年 好的棒球选手
也是好幾年啊
好幾十年的練習啊
對吧
ok 所以這個不行哦
然後那個那個
各位那個Peter同學他在幫大家解股票
Peter是我們以前的同學其中一個
他挑出來的股票我覺得
跟我們的看法其實蠻多都蠻近的
所以不錯
我现在也能够不看chart看tick吗不行 我没有办法我其实我看着那个tick在跳我大概看得出来像刚刚我们不是在
刚刚在这里
刚刚我不是开这样子吗
那当时我们看到是不是到97下不去
然后到上面到100多
然后又下来到104 103
我们刚刚在直播的时候讲的
有没有
所以在我的脑袋里面
其实我已经有一个97上去回来下不去下不去
我已经有这样子的图形感在我的脑袋里面了
我记得我玩过这个游戏啊
像我每一次去
去那个大学里面讲课
我之前都还有了
最近没有了
都还去大学里面社团帮他们讲课
那我都会跟大学生们玩那个游戏
就是直接用喊的
我就在喊一支股票
100 101 102 99 98 101 102 99 98
99 98 105 105 107
然后要他们从我念出来的数字去评估
眼前这支股票正在往上走还是往下走
它的楼梯是怎么样子的
这样
不会 我不会用TIG来判断力道
我不会再看什么这里挂多少口
这里挂多少口
那太累了
太累了
不需要
那样子你会直觉的钻到非常短的短线里面
纹10
可能1万个
可能10万个
只有一个人有办法做到那样子
纯Tick
然后看着这样子的那个力道
不需要
图形会说话
而且你不需要在很短的图形去跟他拼
不用
好不好
还会加仓吗
它如果再下不去才会
如果它
我现在我希望的Oracle
我不会在这里加
因为我不喜欢
因为它再下去我就觉得不对了
那我想要的加仓
我希望它能够在这个附近
回来到200这附近
如果我回来
这些地方会是我
我比较觉得可以的地方
我目前应该就没有打算再继续夹
这样
对啊
因为我也不喜欢让自己的部位
过度的变成这种一路凹下去这样子
虽然它不会侵蚀到我的总资本
但是我就不喜欢这样子对啊好好不好代耳 代耳看一下代耳 代耳
有人说左边这个可以加
可以啊 你只要把这个
它可以 你把这个拉开来
这个
你可以拉 拉开来
底下这边 例如说我要加DEL
代耳电脑
就有啦 我就加进来了
锁住
儲存
你看我就多了一個代額
代額你要問什麼破底翻有點腦部
是喔是喔
不行喔這個不行
喔不行喔來來來
這邊一個好的案例
一個好的破底翻
你會很清楚的一秒鐘就看到那個破底翻的樣子
而不是
有點卡卡的你知道嗎
他底下的边界有好多人在这里
对吧
然后呢
上面的边界好多人在这边
哇
不要了啦
好不好
然后
光宝科
我看一下台股
准备要下课了
好不好
多少
嗯
嗯?是?等一下是你打错还我打错?
我用中文好了光报
2301啦
哈哈老大2301啦
12月16
哦对了那个我按锁是因为我要锁住画面了
你在这边可以直接加
不用这个 你只要拉就可以了
我是因为那个按锁画面这样
你刚刚说你在12月16
吃这151
等一下哦
12月16
不就这两天
16在这里
吃151
这周大碟他都逆势站上去151
觉得很撑
等一下 等一下 来
你的脑袋里先把一件事拿掉
不要觉得大盘这么跌这么多
我的股票很强
他应该很厉害
把脑袋里想的任何一句话都拿掉从今天开始在交易的时候你就不要管大盘发生什么事你要管的是管我眼前这只股票发生什么事
这样好不好
然后呢
你吃在151好吃了点我觉得可以
但是这个可以
是站在周线的
对不起我收回
我觉得
的
来
两天前各位请跟我一起一起看
151 151在这里
来哦 请看一下你吃单的时候
你吃单的时候本来的支撑
在你面前变成什么东西
这一段
变成什么 哎 压力呢
你说下不去哦
对啊 但是
对吧
那你在做日线单
记不记得我说过
我做日线单我有个习惯
我一定会往上看一下周线长什么样子
周来周线来了
哇
这种周线
老鱼老鱼对到这里来
没有没有
他短期喷这么多
前一次的盘整在这个地方
对吧
远远的对过来
这个已经是2023年7月到9月的时候的高点
这种我就不理他了
所以简单的说
这个
你像我赚钱
我不建议你再继续太用力的加
反而是如果跌回来你的成本
我建议你就成本价先走吧
那个手续费什么就给他没关系
成本价就先走吧
因为他的样子
他这整个
整个这个东西
他不是长在
他不是长在低下的这种
低位接的地方
它是长在这里
并且刚出现这种一个一个
你看头一直下来
底部也一直慢慢这样下来
它的力量
如果你是在
它今天假设这几天长上去
然后呢
我用接的
假设是这样
这里接我玩
假装一下
假裝他是這樣子
長上去回來在這裡
你在這裡這個吃
我會覺得這個比現在好多了
因為他至少
把本来的地板又重新增幅过回
增幅回来不是天花板
他脚抬高回来的
对吧
那我这样再赌说他以后会上去
至少这边有第一次的抬脚啊
那我赌后面会上去是比较合理
这个不是真的
我只是拿这个来假装是
上去又回来这样子在这种地方
这会相对好很多
这样好不好
好了
3035日线算是标准图吗
日线
不行不行不行
来来来一个好的标准图
它不会出现在一个这种
这种这种地方而且你看哦
这个标准图你看起来你稍微再退一步看
哇你看到周线
它其实是在一个
一大堆
一大堆不上不下
不上不下的地方在这里
这样
它在中间也不知道要干嘛
市场也不知道要干嘛
不要不要不要
好不好
这个标准图很硬
不要哦
好不好
刚刚好像看到有个同学
写一大堆英文
那是什么啊
这里
从明月到今到今
我已获得Express account
整个的15次
但无论他们都能够达到资金
非常受苦
应该我应该会给Marlene
你应该是听得懂中文对吧
这个
我想要拿这个来当
I come from Taiwan
I am from Taipei City
等一下
你自己就住台北
你干嘛打英文
可能这样或比较容易被我看到
对不对
你说你拿到过15个Express帐号
你要放弃吗
我建议你不要用放弃这两个字
但是你需要停下来调整
这倒是真的
因为你如果都能够打到Express
代表你前面在没有资金压力下的过程中
你是ok的
那你到底进入到Express帐号以后你做了什么事情多了什么心理的压力跟你原来通关的这个过程是不一样的你是乱赌通关的吗
还是你是乖乖慢慢做通关的
这有差哦
那你到底是哪一种
所以你需要停下来
那我建议你既然你有15个Express帐号
你可以列出
列出
每个账号
例如说我这个账号报掉
你去检查一下那个账号
我报掉我做了什么不该做的事
第二个账号
我做了什么不该做的事
第三个账号不该做的事
第四个账号不该做的事
你会发现这15个账号
几乎都做同一件事
你可能是有某一个习惯一直都没有改
以至于你拿到就报
拿到就报都无法出经
那你需要先停下来
不见得要放弃
但是如果你照着原来的方式继续做
那是没有意义的
就是一直花钱刷卡 花钱刷卡这样而已
对吧
你要做的是好好的静下来
你用纸笔把它写下来比较有温度
然后看着电脑萤幕上面写一下
我到底做了哪些事
好好的检讨
然后给自己个反正接下来年底
给自己个十天半个月
甚至你直接休息到一月都没关系
让自己好好的沉淀休息一下
然后休息之后你要重新考试再重新来
那考试的时候就拿着你那张
那个你刚刚写完的
你的缺点嘛
你做什么事爆掉的这一张嘛
你就把它贴在旁边的墙壁上
然后看着这些东西
然后看着自己眼前的帐
然后跟自己说
我不要再做这些无聊的事情了
对吧
这样好不好
你需要做这件事
ok
对自从没有了群组
每个礼拜四都一个半小时
不然平常我讲到十点我就要下课
最慢对吧
因为我以前我都还有第二堂十点的课
这样
ok
开头
那个贴图里的话题
记得让我
你说这里吗
你说这个吗
我看后面还有没有东西
应该没了吧
最后先讲这个结论待会再来聊最后的东西最后留一点时间的聊天我说大家都不愿意慢慢变有钱我刚刚前面讲到很多那种地方都是
我自己也是啊
我刚前面讲的案例都是我
因为我以前很苦
很苦你就想要赶快翻身
结果你越快想翻身
结果变翻船都没有翻过去
所以就很讨厌你知道吗
我是到了现在
包含辅导过这么多同学
我才慢慢体会到
原来大家都要求快
不是只有我
被诈骗集团骗走的那些人
其实他们也在求快
求又快又稳定
对吧
那就是诈骗
那大家都舍不得
所以我刚才会说
这种像这种少
但是更好
那少怎么会是更好
越多才是越好啊
对吧
所以我才会觉得
慢才是快
我很喜欢这种观念
尤其在交易上面
你越慢
你一回头你会发现
其实你已经赢很多很多了
好不好
那这真的才是最适合大家
OK
然后这个待会再来念
我们先来聊一下这个
一开始丁选的留言
你说
不堪回锁的鬼打墙
来走出迷雾的关键
我跟大家说
我的人生里面
它没有那种像电影一样
被蜘蛛咬一下
突然间就变成蜘蛛人
然后或是被X光照一下
突然间就变成绿色的皮肤
我的人生的翻身
它其实很频繁
它没有一个关键的那种
一个点
哇 突然间就通了
没有
我为什么能够走出来
你知道吗
因为到中间我真的某个程度来说
我放弃了
我对交易不抱着希望
因为我当时也没有钱
然后做期货需要钱
买股票也要钱
我当时有负债又养两个小孩
我需要钱来过生活
所以那段时间
我有好一段时间
好几年吧
一两年两三年我忘记了
我是完全没有交易
我的心思都放在当时在做的工作上面
我就想是把当时在做的事情给做好
当时我老婆也在保险业甚至有一段时间我们的家庭是靠着我老婆撑过那个家庭最惨那段的收入是他撑过来
然后让他去工作
我在家里雇两个小孩子
还没有上幼稚园的小孩子
这样
就是那段时间我想说在家里
就一边下单就赔很多
对啊
所以
你说有办法走出来吗
我走出来的关键是我放弃要走出来这件事
如果你一直想着我要走出来
你就会走不出来
请你好好的去琢磨
我刚刚讲这段话
你越想要打棒球
你就越打不到这颗棒球
打击也是这样子
我有在打棒球
就是这种感觉
你越想要投进去就偏偏投不进去
那你越想要脱离苦海
我前面讲的那些案例都是
我好想要脱离苦海
然后却越陷越深
因为你会很执着的
一直执着在那个结果上
但是大家都忘记
其实过程的本身就已经很美好
但是你都忘记去享受
这个当下的过程
所以我也是这样跟我的小孩讲
我说你要做的其实就只是把
当下的这件事情
做好
这件事情会对于你以后
有帮助没帮助
无所谓
那以后的事情
这样
你就把当下给做好
你现在学这个
跟以后有没有关系
没有关系
反正你就做好就对了
在当下你负责任
把这件事情扛起来
然后走一步算一步
就这样走
以后先不用管
它会自己发生
但是某一天
你会回头过来看
回头过来看
跟贾博士讲的一样
你的人生会从后面回头
往前面连起来
你就会感谢你自己说
还好我在过去的这些阶段
我都很认真的对待
当时做的工作
当时所读的学业
当时所做的事情
那你到最后这些
才有办法连到现在的
这样
所以你说走出来
没有那个
我已经放弃走出来
结果我就不知不觉走出来
那最后我不是有一本书吗?
西营立法则的书
就是
真人实证
我靠西营立法则赚到三千万
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕